[Music]
hey you guys
it's sunday kind of a rainy sunday here
in central florida a little bit rainy
kind of cloudy yeah we're going to do a
movie that sophie sent me a long time
ago we never got around to seeing it
called sexy beast yeah i had seen it
before i actually think i saw this in
the theater back in 2000 i'm not
mistaken yeah but you had never seen it
no i've never seen it before we start
the show um
went down it was at the [ __ ] biker
bar
or with the oasis
it's only there for two hours
and when it showed up
got a damn
uh
tequila
and little amy
goes
hey uh hey tom
you know that crackhead girl i was like
yeah he goes dead
i said no ray remember the one i said
the crackhead girl when i took a video
the one that you took a video she's dead
holy [ __ ] yeah i was saying like look
somebody's gonna pick her up and kill
her you guys so you guys gotta [ __ ]
get her some help somewhere
i was thinking that it was gonna be a
some kind of serial killer or something
pick her up because she get in the car
with anybody
yeah i got a motorcycle picked her up
and killed her
[ __ ] wipe that damn motorcycle out
the the the rider's in [ __ ] like
critical condition and she's dead she's
dead on impact that's horrible they were
[ __ ] tripping balls high
he was on a sport bike
yeah don't do drugs and ride motors yeah
yeah i mean don't do drugs and drive
cars yeah
but you know
[ __ ] they're tripping balls on [ __ ]
methamphetamine riding sport bikes
that's horrible i wouldn't let that girl
in the back of my bike she doesn't
shower
but i guess if you're into that you know
yeah i mean they you know
that's that's kind of a bummer isn't it
yeah every time i see her she hadn't
showered in like four or five days
she was funny though she had other
priorities yeah she was funny yeah
it always [ __ ] only only saw her once
when she made any sense she's mostly
nonsensical
you know sounds like that's just crazy
to me that you just like [ __ ] that
you just
started talking about her a couple weeks
ago and then like showed me that video
of her and now she [ __ ] died and was
like how did you know she was gonna die
i said just had to feel like she was
gonna die because that's weird yeah and
i said yeah
i didn't i didn't give her any more
background than that i knew she was
gonna die
it was like i do
yeah i said it on the show i said that
girl's gonna die yeah she did she had
like a like a black cloud over there she
died yesterday yeah that's [ __ ] up
yeah
[ __ ] up well what was she gonna do
yeah it wasn't gonna turn out i mean she
was young though right uh yeah 22 22 23
24 i think i think he says he was 24.
man was that right right it was 24 i
think it was that's awful yeah
murder hornet says uh am i the only one
talking i see nobody else's chats yeah i
don't see anybody else's chats either
yeah yeah i'm talking is anybody else in
here uh there's seven in there oh okay
so just everybody's being quiet like
just uh waiting for us to probably start
talking about the movie right
okay so um
sexy beast
british gangster movie
about some uh british gangsters
this one uh guy this guy he's kind of
semi-retired he's living in uh
spain
and uh the group that he works for
[ __ ] tries to call him out of
retirement
uh and they use this dude he's [ __ ]
nut
nuts
played by ben
kingsley
and he's just [ __ ] psycho
totally out of his [ __ ] mind it is
funny it's a funny [ __ ] show it is
it's it's a funny movie yeah it's a
funny movie it's uh
it's kind of like this but it's funny in
a way a gangster movie would be funny
you know it's kind of like uh
uh [ __ ] goodfellas or
[ __ ] you know casino or something
like that yeah it's like a dark comedy
honestly it's kind of like i mean if you
liked um a lot of the kind of british
crime drums like you know the limey or
lock stock into smoking barrels or
snatch
or the long good friday which i kind of
feel like was good but wasn't quite as
funny as this then and if you haven't
seen this one because i here's the weird
thing i'm pretty sure i saw this movie
when it came out because i really like
british movies and i really like british
crime movies
and i really like ray winstone so i went
to see this in the theater i think
and
uh ben kingsley actually got nominated
for
an oscar for best supporting act he
didn't win but he got nominated
so i kind of feel like you know there
was kind of a moment where everybody was
talking about this movie and talking
about his performance in it because he's
amazing and he was like really playing
against type but then after that i kind
of feel like i don't know i kind of feel
like when people are talking about
british crime dramas they bring up you
know like snatch or something like that
but they don't really bring this one up
as much even though this one is like
every bit is good
the thing about this one that's really
interesting
is that even though yes it's technically
a british gangster movie
i kind of like that they sort of subvert
your expectations it's not really
there is the trope in it of you know
coming out of retirement for one last
job
but the actual heist which is like a
bank job is like an afterthought it's
not really yeah it's not really even
about that yeah um the whole focus of it
is basically on
ben kingsley's character whose name is
don logan
trying to
get ray winston's character gal
to come back into the thing and like all
the [ __ ] psychological manipulation
and crazy [ __ ] that he does
to get him to come back yeah and he's
crazy too he's not some criminal
mastermind he's [ __ ] crazy
i think that's kind of why because prior
to this
i don't really know because ben kingsley
i mean up to this point yeah he played
gandhi and stuff like that but he's kind
of known for playing more kind of like
soft-spoken kind of roles things like
that and i think this is the first time
that he had played something like this
like a villain like this ben kingsley
being a good classy flick or he'll be in
a piece of [ __ ] like blood rain he was
in blood right
well yes of all times
is it wasn't that um what's that what's
that fucker's name that
that no the um that director yeah
director yeah
how do you pronounce his name
the one that if you don't like his
movies he wants to like challenge you to
do a boxing match yeah
but it has that russian girl that uh
played the vampire she was the one that
played [ __ ] from from fifth element
yeah yeah yeah
yeah that had been kingsley and that
that [ __ ] was a [ __ ] stinker i don't
think i ever saw that movie because well
just i just heard how bad it was i saw a
[ __ ] 10 minutes of it it was so
watchable i said no i ain't watching
this
it was just immediately unwatchable
but yeah so uh all right so what happens
in this movie like i said
yeah ray winstone he's uh you know he
was some kind of you know i i was led to
assume they did like bank jobs and
things like that
so
you know he's a british gangster but
he's retired now uh he lives in spain in
this really really nice
villa yeah with his wife dede who he
seems to love very much genuinely she is
a retired porn star
and they live there and then they also
have these two like another couple that
are like their best friends um h and
jackie
and they have also kind of like retired
for the thing so they're like very happy
they lay by the pool
and
you know just hang out and they just
don't want to like have anything to do
with
uh the british crime scene anymore
they're out of it
so
when it turns out the coolest thing i
think about ben kingsley's character in
this
is that even before he shows up on
screen
you can't wait to see like what this
dude is gonna do because as soon as
jackie says they all go out to dinner
one night and jackie says i got a phone
call
and and he says it's from dawn and
everybody you can see everyone's butt
pucker you know what i mean and just
kind of like and so you immediately know
that this is a dude that is like
terrifying they're all like terrified of
him clearly
and you don't know why that is you don't
know like what his deal is but yeah
everybody just sits there and their anus
clenches like oh [ __ ] because they know
very much that it's like if don
wants you to do something
uh there's no way that you're gonna be
able to say no to him because
he is a [ __ ] lunatic yeah he's not a
physically intimidating guy in any way
he's
pretty scary and they wanted somebody
like that they i think they asked gary
oldman first but they said we want
somebody that's not a big dude we want
somebody that's smaller but can play
crazy yeah
and i definitely think i mean ben
kingsley in this is
terrifying
he's just like a terrified i think he's
terrifying because just unpredictable
yeah you have no idea
and the thing about it is that you can
tell that he's
clearly a lunatic
but he there's also like a weird
intelligence behind it like he knows
when not to act like a lunatic you know
what i'm saying like he can act not
normal but he can act in a way that kind
of just gets him what he wants and [ __ ]
like that but then so he's not like
to total complete psycho that can't
control himself he's very very
controlled but he knows when to
release the crazy like to get people to
like to do what he wants but you never
know exactly what he's gonna do he's
like super unpredictable maybe that's
what it is it's hard to tell if he's
unleashing it or if he's holding it back
yeah
i mean yeah it could be either thing
yeah
but that well yeah there's like that
like he holds it back a lot of the times
but then he can't it just
because there's it's like he's crazy but
he's pretending to be sane
yeah yeah i definitely think that that's
the case and that and that uh the sanity
kind of falls away and he [ __ ] acts
like a maniac
he's got a dude that's [ __ ]
says i'll [ __ ] kill you you know he's
making all these threats and just out of
the blue you know i've always loved you
in the middle of all
like something from [ __ ] uh you know
the [ __ ] dude from [ __ ] what was
it what was that david lynch movie with
the guy [ __ ] breathing the damn gas
oh yeah
like dennis hopper's character yeah
dennis frank booth yeah yeah it's like
that what was he in that movie blue
velvet blue velvet yeah he's kind of
like that kind of a dude but not quite
as i mean he's a lot more controlled
yeah i mean frank booth was just like a
[ __ ] balloon
but this guy's a lunatic too yeah not
sexual well kinda is
yeah and interestingly i was reading
something about this movie where ray
winstone the guy that plays gal he said
he almost sees this more of like a love
story than he does like a gangster movie
which i can totally see that because
it's more it's really really focused on
i mean there's a lot of other characters
and there's a lot of other stuff going
on but the the kind of heart of the
movie the focus of the movie is on
this sort of like psychological
the battle of wills i guess like between
these two guys because gal really really
does not want to go and do this job
anymore he's retired he's happy where he
is you know he's just laying around in
the in his back getting fat in spain
like having good food laying around
drinking they make fun of him for
getting fed with his wife and stuff yeah
like at the end of talking about how his
like [ __ ] skin looks like he looks
like a leather bag or something yeah
yeah they do [ __ ] he kept amping up
all the insults and he started to insult
his girlfriend and sold everybody else's
wives and just you know like yeah i
[ __ ] her and he did [ __ ]
and he'd come back you know and then
he'd say [ __ ]
and then he's going he was bagging on
bagging on his wife for being the next
porn star and that he'd seen all the her
videos and everything that she did in
those videos and just he's
he's [ __ ] brutal i mean yeah
that would not fly in an american
[ __ ] uh organized crime
scene he did that to [ __ ] in the
italian old school italians say they'd
kill you
[ __ ] it wouldn't matter well i mean
that's kind of what how this how it goes
[Laughter]
you couldn't do that in the biker world
they wouldn't care what your rank you
were whatever they kill you
i mean the thing about like i said
everyone is kind of
i i just really like all the scenes
where because he pretty much like he
flies there
you know because he calls first and says
hey i want gal for this job and gal's
like i don't really want to do it and
he's you know and he's like oh and i
have to tell him that i don't want to do
it and i don't think that's going to
work out too well but he just like
basically shows up
in spain and uh essentially is like hey
i'm going to stay at your house is that
all right you know what i mean of course
it has to be but it's like everybody
hates him like i said and it's just kind
of like everybody no one can say
anything around him because everybody's
afraid that they're gonna that he's
gonna go off because they never know how
he's gonna react to [ __ ] but it turns
out there's a lot more to it than that
yeah there's guys above him and
um
they're trying to get this [ __ ]
they're trying to get into this second
safe deposit boxes
and the main boss that found out about
the safe deposit box met the guy that
managed the bank the bank manager yeah
the bank manager they met him he met him
at an orgy a high-class origin [ __ ] and
it's inferred from what they showed that
the gangster dude gave the [ __ ] gave
up some ass yeah to that dude ian
mcshane you're right it's the gangster
teddy bass yeah yeah yeah gave up some
ass to that dude in order
to ha get access to the vault to the
vault
so he would know i guess how to steal
from there yeah he was trying to case it
yeah just case it out so the fact that
he met this bank manager at this orgy
you're right and then like this high up
criminal yeah ian mcshane's pretty scary
in this too yeah and uh it's basically
like yeah i'll let this dude [ __ ] my
[ __ ] me in there yeah and you see
they're gonna see you in this [ __ ]
case his face was the other dude's
[ __ ] diving off into him
[Laughter]
dude and he's just like let him do it
like to get the information the
information for the [ __ ] money yeah
and then like uh
man
there's no money [ __ ] there's no
money worth that
that dude went through
but then like
just safe deposit boxes
so he goes through that
and then they get the [ __ ] at the end
that's pretty good
they track that manager down because
the gags are convinced that bank manager
i guess that they were fred's he goes
over south five o'clock in the morning
they knock his ass off yeah and just
[ __ ] shoot him just in total gold
yeah just to silence everybody
um but uh that was a pretty good movie
pretty good movie a bunch of [ __ ]
happens in it don't want to spoil it all
it's not that it's not that yeah i don't
really want to spoil the end but i will
say one of the things i love about this
and this is actually
i think like the um
honestly the screenplay for this is like
really really well written it's very and
there's surprisingly little
improvisation which will uh
probably be very shocking when you watch
it because it seems like a lot of it's
improvised but i don't think it is
and it's actually like pretty short it's
only it's less than 90 minutes yeah the
movie kind of reminded me of cross
between like bronson and the big
lebowski it's kind of like the big
lebowski was kind of meandering in a way
yeah
and it was kind of like that imagine big
lebowski is a [ __ ] gangster movie
this is kind of i don't know if i'd say
well yeah i see what you're saying like
kind of like meandering but then there's
kind of like this tension the whole time
because like i said you're not because
ben kingsley is just like this little
dude who's clearly like a psycho who's
like a crazy person and you never really
know what he's gonna do in any situation
but the tone of the movie is kind of
friendly in a weird way it's like it's
the tone is kind of like a fun movie
yeah i mean it's definitely it's
definitely a comedy but it's a black
kind of crime comedy so it's kind of
like like it's not a zany comedy but
it's that it's that very droll like
british yeah kind of comedy
and
uh and honestly guys are ridiculous
these dancers are ridiculous
they say [ __ ] that's just totally
inappropriate
and i had to have the subtitles on i
couldn't understand everything that they
were saying well it's like super cockney
yeah i could understand everything so
i mean uh so that's what's kind of fun i
mean i was trying to think of like some
of the funny [ __ ] that ben kingsley says
it's one of the things that made me
laugh out loud because i had seen this
before but i hadn't seen it for a really
long time one of the things he says
they're all sitting around in gals uh
gallon his wife dede's living room
and they're all like just sitting there
drinking like like i said with their
butts clenched because nobody's
everyone's afraid to say anything and
then finally like ben kingsley says
something to to dede says something like
you have beautiful eyes i never noticed
before they real
[Laughter]
are they real for eyes so it's just like
he just says like the funniest [ __ ]
[ __ ] like all the time it's just it's
hysterical he's a hysterical hysterical
character and it's just i love all the
interactions because one of the things i
really like about the british crime
thriller about british movies in general
is that nobody
swears like the british
their swearing is like an art form you
know what i'm saying and it's just the
[ __ ] they come up with
is just [ __ ] hysterical to me um i
was reading i saw like a review of this
earlier like on youtube and somebody
commented something really funny at the
bottom they said you know like uh in my
entire life or maybe this was on a b
club i think in my entire life i've only
heard the word [ __ ] in real life like
three or four times until i saw this
movie i mean like pretty much every
other word
is like [ __ ] or [ __ ] because that's you
know what i mean because the uk
it's a much worse word in the united
states i feel like and it's usually more
of like a gendered term like you would
call it to a woman uh whereas in the uk
it's still like offense it's still a
swear word but they usually use it to
like talk to another dude yeah um just
that calling to the [ __ ]
yeah and it's like i kind of feel like
they don't usually direct it at women i
mean they probably do but i kind of feel
like when if they're gonna direct
something at women uh like uh some kind
of slur term it's usually something like
slag or bent or something like that
whereas like if they say [ __ ] they
usually say it to another dude
um they might direct it to women too i'm
not sure but they they use it a lot more
frequently than uh than an american one
uh just think when i was in korea
there's no swearing in the korean
language evidently there's no swearing
in japanese either they don't have a
very good grasp of it
and i i can't imagine it
god if i couldn't swear i would i don't
think i'd be able to talk no there's
just no swearing
i wouldn't be able to talk ever it's not
in the japanese or the korean language
so none of that [ __ ] so i could imagine
what the damn
well they can't even think that way we
had to train them to swear when they
were in our unit
you know i mean they just
well you know they're like like well
look then you you try to explain to them
what that swear meant and they were like
well is that bad yes that's
just that bad that's bad what he just
said he said that your mother gives the
ass up to this dude and that
that busload of dudes and you're one of
the products that's a bad swear oh
that's bad yeah that's bad
wait baby to them it's not bad they're
like
my mom's popular what's wrong with that
they're just you've got i'm not making
that up you guys have researched it
there's no there's no concept of
swearing they're so pot so polite they
can't swear they're [ __ ] there's
whole reaction videos of people talking
to japanese and korean people giving
them american and british swears and
then they asked them what they think it
means and it's just the most [ __ ]
atrocious swearing ever
and uh they they don't understand what
it means
when they try to decipher it and then
when it's explained to them they're like
oh
is that bad
[ __ ] is bad that means you [ __ ]
your own mom yeah uh yeah what about
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah
it's not in their culture
so you know [ __ ] in the army was
[ __ ] filthy so you know we'd have all
our katusas out there y'all
[ __ ] look like they've got gaps
just [ __ ] all kinds of stuff and
they're like what the hell is going on
they wouldn't understand it a little bit
and then you try to explain it took it
too so you know you just said
he said you were homosexual
i'm not homosexual he said you are you
are now
he's made you the homosexual what just
you know
well it's like they're just sitting
there going well why why does it matter
if he thinks that yeah maybe that's
where they're coming they're just like
oh
they're like i don't care if he thinks
that i'm not so yeah right yeah which in
a way is kind of like a good attitude to
have i guess because they don't get
offended but they don't grow up in
school they're not grabbing schools
swearing at each other
i'm honestly from a linguistic
standpoint i'm actually fascinated with
swearing and honestly um because
swearing
i'm not sure if this is still like i'm
not like a linguistics professor
obviously but swearing comes from a
slightly different
part of your brain
than your regular language does because
it usually is you know there's usually
like a lot more emotion behind it and uh
studies have also shown that people who
swear when they you know get hurt uh
they don't feel pain as much because it
sort of like lets off some steam and
also people that swear more tend to be
more intelligent also and many many
studies have shown that um
but honestly like i said
i love
compound swears so i think that's kind
of why i like a lot of the british
wearing because they have all kind of
like crazy ass like compound swear words
like i said like [ __ ] womble and stuff
like that which i think are like really
really funny and there's like just all
i don't know there's um who is the guy
that play i think he played dr who peter
capaldi and he wasn't he on that tv show
and he was kind of like in the uk and i
can't remember what it was but he was
kind of known for these like
ridiculously constructed like swears
that were like really creative and stuff
and i used to have like all these kind
of like memes that had spelled some of
them out some of them like [ __ ]
hilarious but
yeah this movie um yeah if you're if
you're offended by
by the words [ __ ] or cut uh pretty much
every third word is one of those two
words
[Laughter]
you remind me this is reminding me
corporal sung he he could swear he but
he had been in the u.s army as a katusa
for [ __ ] two years he could swear
and he would he would say so much he
would say some cool [ __ ]
because you have to make up your own
well yeah that's that's what i like
about it i like when people that can
make up their own like creatives and he
would like sit back and smoke a
cigarette like that you know in his
[ __ ] uniform and come up with a
[ __ ] way of insulting you
you know and he'd assault american
soldiers it was [ __ ] artistic pretty
good
but he was like uh he was a he was a he
was a con he was a korean phenom he was
a [ __ ] he was he was uh unusual the
other other koreans didn't do that he he
understood the gang
what the heck song
you're all named song parker
they're all named song parker quack all
of them
yeah i thought park was like the most
common isn't that the most song park and
queen
yeah
that's what i've heard the last names
yeah that's what i've done but they you
know that was like the smith of korea
right yeah
you can't find them
yeah
but i was just uh when you were go when
you were talking about the uh the scene
with ian mcshane in this movie before i
was thinking of that scene with uh ben
kingsley and uh ray winston in the bar
where he was like taught where ben
kingsley is like talking about something
else and then all of a sudden talking
about jackie that that other guy's wife
it says yeah i [ __ ] her and then
something like something like how they
were [ __ ] and like then suddenly like
she's stuck she's stuck her
and it was so random and then like he
just goes and starts talking about she's
trying to stick her finger by us what
kind of woman does that
this movie just [ __ ] it cracks me up
so much and i was getting it he goes i
loved her yeah
and then yeah because they're trying to
like imply that maybe he came there not
just for
like to get gal he wanted to like see
her even though she was clearly like
also terrified of him she hated it and
hated him and was so you're kind of led
to believe
that maybe was it consensual was i mean
i was right if she yeah that's what i
mean it's like
you know right yeah right yeah i mean
maybe she stuck her finger up his butt
like to get him to stop
or something like that i would not
really work time ago or he could be
making it up i'm not really
something that happened a long time ago
yeah when they were younger so
one thing that um that i have forgotten
about within like when i watched the the
movie like one of the first scenes you
know very famously the first scene is
like ray winston like laying there by
the pool and he's like you know cooking
like getting sunburned or whatever and
then like
during this one scene
a boulder suddenly like
comes down the mountain
and like lands in his pool and like
breaks the tile at the bottom of the
pool
and the significance of that scene which
actually ties into the plot like later
on at the end the significance of that
scene is like that's a harbinger because
it's almost like
uh ben kingsley's character is like that
boulder like kind of coming down toward
him and you don't know like it's totally
unpredictable so i thought that was like
a really nice little thematic kind of
thing i'm a writer so i like that kind
of stuff but yeah but yeah i i um i
approved them of the movie i uh i
enjoyed it and i want to thank sophie
for sending it to us she sent me a used
dvd copy that came from the [ __ ] one
of the county libraries it's that county
library on it yeah that's all right i
was like okay i got your [ __ ] i got
your [ __ ] [ __ ]
libraries went under and i got i got
their [ __ ] video that's a good thing
to do because you can go there and it's
like sometimes like i said if the
library is getting rid of some stuff you
buy uh yeah you can buy it for really
cheap like books yeah like a buck or
something i used to like uh go and do
that kind of [ __ ] all the time but yeah
this is if you like british crime
thrillers or you know black comedy type
stuff um and you haven't seen this one i
just really kind of feel like you should
i mean ben kingsley's performance alone
is like worth the price of admission
because he's a [ __ ] lunatic it's a
good game but everybody in it is good
and like i said it's a it's good because
it's not like an average gangster movie
where it's
focused on like they do the heist but
the heist is like just kind of like yeah
it goes fine and everything like that
that's not really the main focus of the
movie it's more like a character there's
just a relationship between all these
gangsters yeah so you know they're all
[ __ ] up
so i don't actually know so we watch
this on dvd so i'm not actually sure
where this is streaming but it's
absolutely worth watching so watching
that last night made me want to watch
more
british movies so i told tom i was like
maybe tonight we can watch finally
24-hour party people
because
i've been wanting because i have that
and i've been wanting to like uh
re-watch it and do a review on it for a
long time and you've never seen it and
you probably dig it because like i said
it's kind of it's about joy division and
all that kind of stuff about the
manchester music scene back then so and
it's also funny it's like a black comedy
all right we'll see uh so you'd probably
enjoy it so that we're gonna watch that
oh and you know what's funny after we
watched sexy beast last night we decided
tom was like let's watch the shining
again and i was like okay
shiny was great i never ever get tired
of watching the shining i could watch it
again tonight
that's fine i want to see uh well every
time i see it i've like see something
new in it you know it's one of those
things i like the uh the blu-ray
director's cut of um
dr sleep which is the part two of the
shining it's good
much better than the theatrical release
the actual release had so much cut out
of it just
which i get because they're kind of like
well nobody wants to sit there and you
know because it's i think the uncut ones
well like three hours long yeah if you
guys want if you like the shining
see the uh
director's
cut
a [ __ ] doctor sleep i'm going to go
out on a limb and say that i liked the
movie of dr sleep better than the book
okay um i didn't read the books i don't
know i did uh the book's okay but
i don't know there was something about
the book that i didn't love and you know
i thought the movie was actually quite a
bit better which isn't usually the case
and especially with stephen king's stuff
usually his books are basically i
wouldn't mind seeing the tv the tv
miniseries of the shining you didn't
like it but i liked it
yeah something about that really pisses
me out i wrote like a big long screed
about it like a while back just because
i liked it it was just like the book
pretty much it was just like that's why
i didn't like it yeah well it doesn't it
was too literal yeah well it doesn't it
it doesn't make a good movie no um it
doesn't even really make a very good
movie
this miniseries
but
it is a way of like
remembering what the book was yeah
because it's pretty close to the book
that's
you know the book is always a little bit
i've always said reads a lot better than
[ __ ] when you're seeing that's what
i'm saying book and movie are two
different things and the same thing
doesn't work if if you're gonna make it
just like the book then just read the
[ __ ] book a subscriber
sent us a uh a remastered version of the
tv mini series the stand
and it looks really good it does yeah it
looks really good yeah we enjoyed
watching that again
they had a free version that came off of
vhs
on youtube but it looked like [ __ ] i was
like man i can't remember this thing
looking that bad but the um
the the dvds are real good yeah might be
blu-ray i mean i like that they're
remastered
everything nowadays so it looks like
it's actually supposed to look yeah but
yeah so uh so yeah tonight we're
probably gonna watch 24 hour party
people so that's what we will be talking
about tomorrow
so thanks everybody for dropping by on
this sunday have a good rest of your
weekend and we will see you guys again
tomorrow
bye